the Jefferson family lives on a small
farm in T's Beth Denmark and like most
they use a lot of electricity but this
family is part of a growing trend of
folks who have vowed to decrease their
carbon footprint they create their
electricity with a wind turbine well I
got this windmill because I wanted to
produce some electricity with our
household and I wanted to produce the
twist take carbon dioxide free the
family of seven uses electricity like a
typical household we like using the
computers watching the television and we
like taking hot showers like everybody
else by having a windmill we can do that
with a good conscience because we know
that the power we consume doesn't expose
the environment now we produce
electricity without producing carbon
dioxide it feels the right to take our
little part of the responsibility of
getting better environment right now the
wind is approximately 5.2 m/s and right
now the windmill is producing 4.2
kilowatt and I'll guess that the
household right now is using
approximately two kilowatt so right now
we have an excess production of 2 kilo
it this means that some of the
electricity is sold to other households
and when it is windy the turbine
produces enough electricity for seven
other families their next goal is to
replace one of their vehicles with an
electric car what our future plans is to
reduce this carbon darksied emission
from the cars by changing worth of cars
to an electric vehicle right now it's
not possible to buy one of those cars
because they are not at the market but I
guess there will be at the market during
a year or so and then we will change the
little car for an electric vehicle are
using an electric vehicle we can charge
it from the window during the night we
don't use very much visited during the
night
cause this electricity can either be
used to judge the batteries on the
electric car costs for a home wind
turbine system can vary but materials
alone started a few thousand dollars
u.s.